Ok we're live.
Hi I'm Gari and
John is at home right now.
>> Hi, everybody.
>> And today John is going to
help us set up a Gulp workflow.
So how was your weekend John?
Everyone had a long weekend
in the United States?
Yeah, no I had a pretty
good Fourth of July.
Me and my friends,
we went out to Torino and
we went to a food truck festival which,
I just ate way too much food.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There was also a wing festival, and
we went to that too.
And so I probably ate enough food
to survive for the next week.
So, I guess my diet this
week was nothing but water.
But it was fun.
I gambled a little.
Didn't win big or anything, but
came back with more than I left with, so
that's always good.
But it was fun.
How was your weekend?
>> It was great.
Good, it was quiet, I spent some time
with my niece and just sat at home.
Which was really good.
>> [LAUGH] I know,
that was I think my favorite part,
was when we were all
done doing the stuff and
I got to go sit back at the hotel for
a little bit and just relax.
It was nice to get away.
And it's always fun to
celebrate the Fourth of July
shoveling deep-fried food in my face.
But today I guess the big thing
we're talking about is Gulp.
And so, a couple weeks ago
we did a demo about Grunt,
which is a task runner and
sort of a build tool.
And Gulp is in the same vein as that.
It's here to run minification,
concatenation and
all those kinds of tasks for you, so
you can focus on what's most important
in that's the development of your site.
As opposed to the building
process of your site.
So, I set up a little
demonstration today.
There's a repository as well,
which you can find in the broadcasts
section of the discussion boards.
It's under the title Gulp and
Setting Up a Gulp Workflow,
or something similar to that.
Or it's just
github.com/johnudacity/gulp-start.
And you can follow along with
that repository if you want.
Or if you can-
>> John,
you also posted it in
the broadcast category.
Yes, yes.
And yeah, you can follow along now or
you can download it and
follow along later.
I'll also be posting up
sort of like a short
guide of all the steps we
go through on the forum.
So if you just want to watch now and
then go through the guide later, I think
that's maybe the best way to do it.
because I might go a little fast at some
parts and when I watch people do demos
it's easy for me to miss something and
I'm like, wait a minute I just got lost.
And then I'm spending more time figuring
out how to get back to where they were
than actually listening to them.
So it might be best to just like sit,
listen.
If you think of any questions
feel free to ask them.
But let me start screen sharing here,
and we can get started.
Let me just make sure I'm sharing
the right screen, all right there we go.
So, this is my repository.
I have it downloaded all ready, but
just to kind of give you a little
overview of what it looks like,
there's an index.html file
which has some stuff going on.
There's a CSS folder,
which has some compiled CSS in there.
There's a JS folder that has
some JavaScript in here.
And there's a style folder
which has a stylus file.
So Stylus, for
those of you who aren't aware,
is a little bit like LESS or Sass.
It's a pre-compiled CSS language
which you can use Gulp to
compile into CSS which makes
it usable by the browser.
So we can take a quick peek at this and
see that, right?
It kind of looks like CSS but
the syntax is all a little weird.
So what we're going to be using today
is we're going to be using Gulp,
which is known as
the streaming build system,
to basically automate our workflow,
automate a bunch of these processes that
we probably don't want to have to think
about when we're working on our project.
So, I'm going to take you
from installing Gulp,
to setting it up,
to running a few basic tasks,
to setting up maybe some more
advanced tasks if we have time.
So let's get started.
So the first thing we actually
need before we begin using Gulp
is we need to make sure we have
Node J.S. installed on our system.
Installing Node is really easy,
it works on Linux, Mac, Windows.
All you have to do is
you go to nodejs.org.
And you click this big old
INSTALL button right here.
It'll download some stuff, and
then you just run the executable.
And it'll set up Node on your system.
If you have any problem setting up Node
feel free to mention that in the forums,
I'd be happy to help debug them.
But it usually works pretty well.
An easy way to check I think,
is if you do node-v it should spit out
the version of Node in your
terminal on Mac and Linux.
On Windows I believe it
downloads the Node shell.
Which you just open up and you run all
your Node commands from there, and
hopefully that shouldn't be broken.
I think it's easier to break Node on
Mac and Linux than it is on Windows.
Is my text big enough on my terminal,
Gari?
>> Yep, looks good.
>> Ok, cool.
So once you have Node, the next step
is to navigate into your [COUGH].
So I'm in my project that I
want to begin Gulping here.
And I need to install Gulp, or
I need to set up Gulp on this project.
So when you install Node you get what's
called a Node Package Manager or
npm, and
you can use the command npm install
to install just about any
Node package available.
And you can search for the Node
packages on the Node Package Manager.
But for our case we're using Gulp so
we're going to use npm
install --save-dev gulp.
So this is going to take just a second
and we can see that it's doing
something, and my dog seems to be very
interested in something, come here dog.
There we go, so it's all install.
So now if we look at our project
directory we see we have
this one folder that was created,
which is this Node modules folder.
And if we take a look at what's
inside there we see we have Gulp.
So basically what the npm
command did was it
looked at the Node servers, it got Gulp.
It brought that back to my project,
it created this Node modules folder, and
then it set up Gulp.
And it got all the necessary files and
dependencies to run Gulp on my system
in this particular project folder.
So now that I have a Gulp, just like
with Grunt, we needed a Grunt file
to basically put all our code in and
run everything.
Here we're going to
do something similar.
We're going to make what's
called a Gulp file.
And so we got our Gulp file.
So let's actually open this up,
and open up our Gulp file.
So, we've got a whole lot of
nothing in our Gulp file.
So let's get started actually
setting up our Gulp file.
So.
When we did the demo with grunt,
grunt we saw, was very much like we set
up a big JSON that sort of
configured all of our operations.
Well, gulp kind of takes a different
way of thinking, different philosophy.
It's very much a convention
over configuration.
So we're actually going to be
writing a lot of JavaScript.
So we're actually going
to start with bar equals
require goal.
So what this is doing is this
is using nodes require module
which you can kind of think
of as like an import.
It's basically importing
this necessary file.
It's looking at the node modules folder,
it's pulling in gulp.
And we're basically just storing it
in this variable gulp to use later.
And grow.gulp all we're going
to be doing is we're going to be
defining tasks.
And so just like grunt there's
a default task we can define.
And a task takes two parameters.
It takes a name, and it also takes, and
actually let me make the text
a little bit bigger.
And it also takes a function,
or some sort of call back.
There's a few other attributes
you can pass in to here, but
this is the pretty plain and
simple all sort of gulp task.
So let's make our function
actually do something and
then we'll see how to run gulp.
Let's just do something simple for now.
Let's just do it simple console log.
I'm running gulp.
Ok.
So we set up our gulp file.
We've set up this really simple task.
So just like with grunt the way we
run Gulp is just with the command go.
And this will run our default task.
So by putting this in,
we're going to run this default task.
And we can see that our
console logged out.
I'm running Gulp.
Fantastic.
So pretty simple set up.
You can also you know create another
task and give it a specific name.
It can just do another
consul.log, or robot.
Save it.
And when we run gulp, you see that
it only runs our default task.
If I do gulprobot So
that's going to run our robot task.
We can specify what tasks we want
Gulp to run by just saying Gulp and
then the task's name.
If we want to run multiple tasks,
say I have another task,is just hello.
Console.log,
hello world.
In my default task or
in another named task.
Instead of using a function as my
callback i can actually specify
an array of method names or task names.
So this is going to run on when I
just use gulp because this is my
default task.
It's going to look at this
array of callback functions and
it's going to first run my robot task.
And then it's going to
run my hello task.
So let me save this and when I do Gulp,
you see that it ran my robot task,
finished my robot task, ran my hello
task and finished my hello task.
Then kind of I ran these default tasks
which was running these essentially.
So that's sort of a basic
way of setting up.
Just basic tasks and go.
Obviously you're going to
want to do a lot more.
But this is sort of the basic structure
of setting up a task that will run
in the terminal elliptical.
So Let's actually figure out now,
how to do something a little bit more
than just logging out to the console.
Obviously you can use Gulp
to do that if you want but
nobody really wants to do that.
You guys are here because you want to be
able to modify files Make things look
really nice and make things perform.
So let's get rid of everything
in my gulp file except for
this var gulp = require('gulp').
And let's install some plugins.
So just like Grunt, Gulp has
A whole directory full of plugins.
There's 1,532 plugins total.
And I mean there's more
getting added every day.
Most of the big ones that
you're probably using in grunt
are probably also have been made for
gulp.
So for example, a popular one,
right, is to concat your files.
There's a gulp-concat.
If you want to, you know,
uglify your files,
which is basically
minify JavaScript files.
You can do that with gulp as well.
So you can search for plugins here,
and if you click on plugin name.
It'll tell you a little
bit about that plugin at
the Node Package manager's website.
It'll tell you how to
install that plugin, so
we would just run this
command in our terminal.
To install the plugin.
And it also gives you a little bit
of a demo of the usage, usually.
And then,
depending on how well it's documented.
Some of the plugins are not
documented very well.
So sometimes you've got to go bug
the uou know GitHub owner to like
explain some things but for the most
part they're pretty well documented.
Just some of them, especially when
you start diving into the really new
plugins is when you'll start finding
one's with kind of bad documentation.
But the ones we're going to be using
today are pretty well documented.
We also see options and any sort
of errors that could be outputted.
So let's run this command,
this npm install --save-dev,
and we're going to do gulp-uglify.
And we're just going to give that
a little bit of a second to run.
That runs and
I'm also going to install one more,
I'm going to install
gulp-rename just because
that's going to come in handy,
that's going to let us rename files
pretty easily without having to dive
into like string manipulation and stuff.
So let's pop open our gulp file again.
And let's include these as well.
So we're going to include uglify,
I can spell.
And we're going to include
our rename plugins.
Using the same code as we did
to include our Gulp file.
Our sorry or go plug and module.
Yes is the right word.
Rename the.
So now we have a glyph which will.
Will use to mina five
I heard JavaScript.
And we also have our renamed which we
use to sort of rename files as we need.
So let's make a new task, and
let's call this one scripts.
This will be our task which we use
to basically run any sort of script
methods.
And let's give it a callback function.
And in this function we're
going to specify a source file,
that we want to act on.
And the way we do this is
we use our gulp module.
And we use it source methods.
So gulp.source and
then we specify what we want to look at.
So specifically we want to look
in the JavaScript folder and
any file that has JavaScript.
So this star is what's
known as a catchall.
What we've created here is
we've created here a glob.
And this glob basically says
look in the js folder, for
any file, any name,
that also includes a .js.
This is a little bit
like regular expressions.
But a little less robust
than regular expressions.
We can also look for any
sub-directories that may be in there.
By using like a double star and
then slash.
So this basically says,
look in the js folder, for
any other folders and then look for
files that have the js suffix.
But since we don't have any folders
in there we're just going to do this.
And now what we're going to do
is we're going to use a pipe.
So gulp is all about using
the input output stream and
a pipe basically pipes either to or
from this string.
You can kind of think of it
like water pipes, I guess.
The source is basically whatever
gets outputed from this,
is going to get piped
into this next method.
So we can chain them together like this,
you can have tons of pipes.
Can get together like that.
But sometimes you might
have a lot of steps.
So usually it's just
easier to add a new line.
Tab it.
Then just line it up like this.
So we're going to pipe
any of the contents that
are gulp.source method finds
into our uglify function.
So basically anything that ends
up getting picked out from this
is going to get shoved into this method.
And then we're going to
get some results and
we're going to pipe that
into our rename method.
And we're going to rename it app.min.js
And then we're going to pipe the result
of that into a gulp.destination.
And we're just going to shove
it into our JavaScript folder.
So let's go ahead and run the scripts
task now and see what happens.
So let's do gulp scripts.
All right so it finished running.
So let's take a look and
see what happens so
we see here that we now have
this app.men.js file which
has all the minified JavaScript
in from our app.js file.
Pretty neat.
Pretty simple too.
I think the nice thing about using
this sort of streaming system as well
is with grunt,
when you use the configuration file,
what usually ends up happening is a lot
of temporary folders get created.
And that ends up taking a lot of
time whereas with this input output
streaming, there's no need to
create these temporary folders.
And everything just kind of
runs a little bit faster.
It may not be as noticeable
on smaller projects.
But as these gulp files and grunt files
get a lot bigger that's when you start
noticing sort of the performance
difference between the two.
So that's great.
Let's do the same thing.
Let's minify our CSS now.
So usually when I'm
working on a project and
I have decided okay,
I need a new step in my build.
I need to minify my CSS, for example.
So we have this or is it our stylist,
and we also have just our regular
CSS that gets outputted from that so
we need to minify that as well.
So let's figure out how to do that, so
what I would do is I would start by
going to the gulp js plugin directory.
And I would look for maybe CSS and
let's see what that gives me.
A bunch of things.
Let's try minify that search as well.
I don't think I want that let's just
try minify CSS and here we have we go.
We have gulp-minify-CSS.
And so this is a gulp plugin
to minify CSS using clean CSS.
So let's use this file
to minify our CSS.
So we're going to use the same sort
of command, mpm install, save dev.
Gulp-minify-CSS.
And I'm going to wait a second for
to install and there you go.
So it's installed, it's set up, if we
look inside our node modules folder we
see that we have
gulp-minify-CSS in there.
So let's actually include that
in our gulp file as well.
So we're going to have
minifyCSS = require(
'gulp-minify-css' ).
And now let's set up a new task.
We're going to call
this our styles task.
And now we're going to
have to specify a source.
In this case we're going
to specify our css folder.
We're not going to do anything
with the stylus file just yet and
we're going to look for
anything that has a dot css.
We're going to pipe that into our
minified CSS function or plug in,
and we're going to spit
that out to a destination.
And in this case we're going to spit
it out to just a minCSS folder.
All right so let's run that gulp styles.
Let it do its thing.
And we see we get a min CSS folder and
we get some minified CSS.
Pretty straightforward I think.
And then let's say we want to
run these both together.
So one way we can do this is we
can just say gulp scripts styles.
And that should run both of them.
But you probably don't want to
have to remember all the different
names of all the tasks
that you want to run.
So usually it's a little easier
to specify a default task.
Or maybe like a like a smaller subset
of general tasks you want to be using.
That just take you know scripts [COUGH].
>> John, there are a couple
of questions [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah.
Can I, let me, yeah.
I'm down to take some
questions right now.
I think this is a good point
to take some questions.
>> [CROSSTALK] Okay, so
that's the basic function I'm sorry.
What was that?
>> Do you want to see the questions
on your screen and answer them, or
do you want me to read them out?
>> No, yeah, feel free to them out.
>> Okay.
So Tom ask, what happens if there is
more than one .gs file in the folder?
>> That's a good question.
So let's take a look.
So let's actually add a new file here,
and let's call this app2.js,
and let's just put in some
filler function here, =b
They're mad because I didn't,
okay, so let's take a look.
So we have this app2 with
some basic JavaScript in it.
Let's see what happened when we
run gulp script in this case.
All right, so it finished running,
and in my app.min.js,
we see that it actually only
minified this new JavaScript file.
The problem with this is it's because
we're not concatenating these
two, first.
So usually what you want
to do in this process,
and it was something I was going to get
to later, was to concatenate your files.
And actually add an extra step
here where you concatenate
them using a concatenation plugin,
and then
pipe them into the minification process,
and then set them as a destination.
As you can see here when we ran this,
it just ran it on the single js
file instead of grabbing all
of them inside this folder.
See that, again.
Yeah, so in this case there's
an Orchestrator error.
Because it's mad concat's not defined.
Yeah, so usually it's best to
concatenate your JavaScript files, or
you need to output them
all to a different name.
So this is a case where using this
rename function wouldn't be a good idea.
Because I'm basically renaming all
of my files to this app.min.js and
spitting them all out to here.
And because it's doing one at a time
it does this one first, spits it out to
here, does this one second, and it
overwrites everything in here with that.
So, usually you should concatenate them,
or specify.
You know, use some tricky stuff here to
specify sort of like an iterative name.
There's a few things you can do.
And we can talk about
those in a little bit.
>> Okay, thanks, John.
>> Thanks, John.
>> So Tim asks, how would you go
about editing original documents
if you have already ran them them for
a task, or
does it keep the original
copy in the same folder?
>> Yeah, good question.
So, typically,
this actually might be a good chance,
let me show you guys a little
bit better structure.
So this is where structuring your
project is really important.
So here's just a little project
that I've been working on.
And so it's important to structure
your project really cleanly.
So here I actually have two folders.
I have an app and a public.
And inside my public folder,
actually pretty much all
my sort of minified code.
Whereas in my app folder I have
basically anything that I'm working on.
Another easy structure
to set up is just to do,
let me just make a simple
test folder here,
is to actually separate a source and
distribution folder.
And in your distribution folder that's
where you're actually going to be sort
of piping all of your outputed,
minified code to and
you're going to do all your
development on the source code.
So, hopefully, you won't have to go
about editing the minified files
because nobody wants to go through and
try and edit this.
You're not going to be
able to find anything.
It's going to be much easier to just
be able to go back and edit this, and
output the results of the minification
process to either a new folder or file.
And it's easiest to organize them as
the source directory, or the development
directory, which is you know where
you're doing all of your work.
And then using gulp or grunt to
build to a distribution directory
where you'll have basically all
your production ready code.
>> All right.
Thanks, John, and thanks,
Tim, for the question.
So Robert asks,
what's the --save dev for?
>> Yeah, so let me go back here.
So typically in a node projects,
I didn't do it this time,
but you should always
include a package.json file.
You can set one up pretty quickly
using the command npm init,
and it'll take you through this
sort of little step-through guide.
And you'll see that it makes
this package.json file.
So let me actually open that up and
show you what's in there.
So this package.json file
tracks all of our dependencies.
There's developer dependencies and
then regular dependencies.
When you do save dev, it should throw
them inside the developer dependencies.
It didn't because I did
this after the fact.
But developer dependencies
are modules and
plugins that you as a developer
are going to be using.
That is, the public version of your site
isn't going to rely on these modules,
or plugins, or frameworks, or whatever.
Standard dependencies are going to
be things like if you include
Angular in your project in
your site depends on Angular.
Developer dependency is, like I said,
are only going to be things that you use
in the development process,
or someone on a team,
or is working your project, should also
be using in their development process.
Because you've included say,
like a gulp file, or
a certain bower components,
and things like that.
That's what the save dev does.
If you want to save just your
dependencies, you can do npm install
--save, and that'll save them
to your projects dependencies.
So, again, dependencies are basically
things that are required for
your app to run.
Developer dependencies are things that
are probably best to install if you plan
on developing on that project as well.
>> All right, thanks John,
and thanks Robert.
Great question.
Stephen asks, where and
how does gif fit with all of this?
>> Yeah, so git and gulp are two very,
very different things.
Git is strictly for version control.
You're going to be using Git to
basically track the progress of
your project, and sort of track
iterations throughout your project.
You can kind of think of it, right,
as you're saving points in time
at where your project's at.
Whereas gulp is largely
going to be used for
minifying and
getting code ready for production.
Oftentimes, these things kind
of come hand in hand and,
as you can see there's a lot
of sort of git plugins.
Let's see git, or I think there
should be some git plugins.
Let's see, gulp, get.
No?
I swear there were some git plugins,
because I've used them before, or
maybe it's just not filtering right,
right now.
Yeah, why didn't I find this?
So, there's a gulp git plug in,
which you can use to actually automate
a lot of your sort of git processes.
So, say you only ever minify your code
when it's at a point that's ready
to be committed, and you maybe just
want to automate that commit process.
Well, they have some
definitions here for
how you could write
tasks that do commits.
They also have how you
can sort of add files.
So you can, I guess,
use gulp to automate your git processes.
But ultimately the reason
you're using git and
the reason you're using
gulp are different.
Git is strictly for tracking
the progress of your project, and
GitHub is for hosting it online.
Whereas gulp is for
getting your code production ready and
automating sort of all of these kinds
of workflows that you'll be doing.
From magnifying concatenating
to compiling things like Stylus,
Sass, CoffeeScript, to watching files
for changes and things like that.
>> Okay, thank you.
A couple of more questions, John.
Michael asked, If you concatenated
the files, and I guess he's referring
to the concat, wouldn't it try
to also include app.min.js?
>> Yeah, you're actually right, and
that's because I'm throwing
it in the same folder,
which is why usually it's a good
idea to have separate folders.
I did not structure this
demo project very well.
So, it would try to include
the app.min.js, but
you can use globs to
ignore files as well.
I believe, let's see here,
there is a way to exclude things using,
I think it's like a double
minus sign in the glob.
It's been a while since I've had
to try to something like that,
but yeah you're right.
It would totally try to
include the app.min.js,
which is why later we would be putting
that file somewhere else inside our
distribution directory for example.
>> These questions keep coming John.
>> That's fine.
I'm totally fine with
just answering questions.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's why I'm here.
>> James asks any chance there
is an unmodified plugin for
working on someone else's production
code [INAUDIBLE] factors and
things where you don't
necessarily have the source.
>> So actually you can do that
right in Google Developer Tools.
And actually there are unminified
plugins as well, but
if you look in the developer tools,
if you go to say the sources.
Let me see if I can find something,
some massive stuff here.
And you actually click on this little
pair of brackets at the bottom here.
It pretty prints it.
The only thing it won't do
that's still a problem is that
during the minification process
it replaces variable names with
single letters to save bytes.
So, as you can see here we have like a,
and you can see it all over the place,
a, a or oa.
There's no real way to sort of unminify
these to their original variable names,
If you don't have the source
maps that you used.
So you would either need to have
a copy of their source maps,
or just have to deal with all the kind
single letter variable names and
kind of figure out
what they're used for.
There isn't a great way to unminify
source code to the original work,
unless you have the source
maps like I said.
>> All right, thanks John.
The next one is from Jeff.
Will this be recorded and
available for viewing later, if so
where can I find it [INAUDIBLE] podcast?
Jeff, if you go in your community.
And in the events, just type grunt or
gulp, the recordings will show up, and
as you can see on John's screen, he's
going through the broadcast category,
where we also posted the transcript
along with the video.
So, I think that should help you.
Let us know if you have any troubles and
we'll make sure we link
you with the video.
Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> More questions, Arvin asks, is there
a way to run these in the background,
so you don't need to
run the tasks manually,
especially while using copy plugin and
such?
>> Yeah, and actually that was one
of the things I was going to hit on,
which is watch tasks.
So, this is now I guess
a good time to do this so.
So, gulp just like grunt let's
you watch files for changes.
So suppose I want to work
on my JavaScript or
my CSS or something and
not have to worry about okay, I made a
bunch of changes, let's compile my code.
I just want it to compile
every time I make a change.
So, what I can do is I can create
what are called watch tasks
And so
the way we structure a watch task, so
it used to be really kind of a pain
in the butt until gulp got updated.
And then they've just sort of included
their own watch functionality.
So now you can just say gulp.watch.
And again, you specify what
directories you want to watch.
And you specify a callback function, so
it works very similar to a task.
So, there's just the files
you want to watch And then.
What tasks are scripts you want to
execute when that file gets to.
Changes get detected in that file.
So in this case we want to
run scripts for my c.s.s.
If you know anything in my CSS changes.
Then I probably want to run my styles
task So let's see what this looks like.
I'm going to this add
this to my default.
And so here we go.
So we see that it runs my scripts.
It runs my styles, and
then it runs this watch task.
And we can see that it's just waiting.
Whereas before when we ran our goal task
it just finished, and then it was done.
Now it's actually sort of idling here
waiting for something to happen.
So let's take a look and
see what happens when we
change something in our CSS.
So let's make this red and save.
We can see over here in my terminal,
that my styles task ran again.
So in case you missed that, I'm going to
make a change one more time, and
watch here and you'll see
something changed let's make our
padding maybe 20 px, save.
And we can see that again
our styles task ran.
So that's basically how you sort of
automate a lot of these processes.
Is by setting up a watch task.
And this becomes extremely
useful when you're developing.
So you don't have to keep jumping
over to your terminal and
saying like blah blah blah blah blah.
You can just go in, work on your CSS,
know that the code is compiling.
You're able to, open up your project and
examine it and watch for changes.
It's really helpful
being able to do that.
And then usually if like a lot of people
usually have a question like okay,
how do I stop watching?
In the terminal if you use control C,
that's just sort of like the kill task.
And that'll take you back to just
sort of the normal terminal.
One thing that may happen, and
I don't know if they actually updated
this since then, was sometimes
if you include a syntax error
It'll stop watching.
So there's a few different methods you
can use to Just throw the error but
not to stop watching.
The one I suggest is you use a plumber,
I believe is what it's called,
gulp plumber.
And this basically prevents the pipe
from breaking when errors occur.
This way when say maybe
you do type an error here
It will spit the error out to you,
but it won't kill the stream.
So in this case, because I'm not using
Plumber, when it threw this error it
just blasted out this glob of problems,
and then it stopped the watch task.
And now I'd have to go in here,
fix this.
And then, run Gulp again
using Plumber is definitely the right
thing to be doing to make sure that
you're still receiving the errors, but
it's not wrecking your build process.
>> Last two questions, John.
So James asked,
you mentioned earlier that Gulp
works best on Macs and Linuxes.
Is there a particular version of Linux
that you would say it best works with?
>> I maybe accidentally said that but
it also works good on Windows.
Just with windows you have
to use the node shell,
as opposed to just being able
to use the command prompt.
I mean you can use the command prompt or
power shell but you're going to have to
do some minor modification and
tweaking and stuff like that.
Essentially, setting up node in
your path environment variable.
As far as versions of Linux which
it works best with, I don't
think there's a version of Linux
that it necessarily works best in.
So Gulp, right,
is just a module for Node, so
any Linux a platform that Node works
fine in, gulp is going to work fine in.
And i think,
Node works in just about any Linux
environment I've ever encountered.
So, you shouldn't have
any problem there.
If you do though, let me know,
I'd love to hear if there is
a Linux platform you're using where your
node, your goal, isn't working properly.
>> I'm not sure if I'm saying your name
right, she asked, how do you handle GIF,
for your source code, GILF code or
even your GH pages for one project?
Do you consider the same old repo?
[INAUDIBLE].
>> So yeah,
I keep them all in the same repo.
There's a few common
patterns out there and
this is actually something I know a lot
of students have been interested, in and
I kind of want to do a write-up about.
But usually what I have is
I have my master branch.
And then I usually set
up two more branches.
The development branch,
right not a valid object name master.
I don't think it will let me do
that until I add this stuff.
And then,
I also make my gh-pages branch.
As far as my source and distribution
code, it all lives on the master branch.
For my gh-pages,
I usually only keep my build.
Code on there all my chief pages
one because that's the code
that is going to be
running on my pages site.
So usually you can specify which
files get merged into that branch and
you can take them out as well.
And then, for my development branch
that's pretty much a mirror of my master
branch and
that's where I do all my development.
And then when I'm ready to push changes,
I'll push changes
from my development branch
to my master branch.
And then from my master branch,
I'll merge any changes into
my get hub pages branch.
And specify that I only want to
merge over my production ready code.
That's getting a little
out of scope of gulp.
>> Yeah.
>> But
that's sort of the process i would take.
You can also, like I said, use gulp
with Git to set up the process for
doing that so all you have to do
instead of having to do you know.
Git add you can just say gulp build.
And maybe that will run through all
these tasks and add the proper files and
commit the changes and push them to
the right repository and branch.
But that's kind of how i set it up.
So I do pretty much all my
work on a development branch.
Push any changes from the development
branch to the master.
And then merge any needed changes
from the master to the pages branch.
>> All right [INAUDIBLE]
>> So,
Alf App, which is more common in your
transcript, could you please list all
the helpful and most reliable plugins,
especially for image optimization.
>> Yeah.
I think I include quite a few of them.
I also share a Gulp file that I use.
Yeah I'll make sure to
include those links as well.
So yeah,
I'll make sure to include those.
>> Thanks John and thanks Al.
You're going to love answering this one,
John.
How do you consider
Gulp better than Grunt?
Assuming they serve the same purpose.
So this is a very opinionated answer.
But yes,
I really like the speed of golf.
I like The way it utilizes node
more than the way Grunt does.
I like the fact that I feel like I'm
writing in JavaScript as opposed to
writing up a configuration file.
However I will say grunt is very
straightforward and very easy.
It's easy to get someone
started on grunt.
Whereas with gulp,
usually to get it to be a little bit
more masterful of it, you have to
have a little bit of understanding
about things like JavaScript promises.
The input output stream.
And those are a little bit more
difficult to learn than just,
here's grunt.
Sure the plug-ins for grunt.
Here's the configuration
file you write go.
To really like dive into the gulp and
get the full power out of it you
do need to know some JavaScript.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> But
in terms of being better than Grunt,
I think it is.
>> All right.
Asks, when watching.
Is there a way to have the browser
free load when a file is changed?
>> Yeah, yeah and that's something that
I'll include in my write up as well
because i don't think we have
enough time to dive into it today.
But you can use I believe
it's called browser sync.
Okay.
Both browser.
There's a great write up on the browser
syncs website on how to use go
Gulp JS with browser synch.
And you can do that.
There's also i think gulp-livereload.
Yeah.
Go plug in for live reload so
you can use it.
There's a a lot of different options.
And then basically all you do is you set
one of the tasks in your watch function.
Say for example,
I set up a browser-sync task.
Then here when there's a change,
it all run my scripts code and compile.
And then it all also run my
livereload or something like that.
So that's kind of what
you would do there.
And then that way,
you can just have your index.html open.
Obviously this isn't going to work,
but you'd be able to watch for
changes here instead of having
to continually refresh.
Thanks, Sean, and thanks,
Lettie for the questions.
Now Michael asks,
how would you integrate testing
with a framework like Jasmine?
There you go.
You've got it.
>> Yeah so, just like Grunt, Gulp
>> If there's something you want to be
able to do, say testing,
git, minification,
just setting up production servers,
anything,
Gulp has plug ins that do that,
more often than not.
So in this case, your specific question,
you were interested in integrating
tests with a framework like Jasmine.
I simply just looked for gulp-jasmine.
And sure enough there is a Gulp plugin
that will run Jasmine tests for you.
You can set up a task, you can specify.
You know what tests you want to run and
you can pipe in the jasmine method.
This one's pretty well documented
it's created by who's a pretty
pretty popular famous
JavaScript developer.
If you're not familiar with him, he's
created quite a bit as you can see here.
But more often than not, there's going
to be a plugin for the task at hand.
So I would say just read
into it a little bit.
This one's very well documented so
it should be pretty easy to figure out.
But Almost anything that you normally
have to manually do while developing
code, a tool like Grunt or Gulp is
going to allow you to automate that.
And it's really,
really great to sort of have these tools
just because it sucks having to do
this stuff manually all the time.
It takes you out of the build
process to have to stop,
open up your terminal, run your tests or
stop, open up your terminal,
run some minification program or,
you know.
Open up your index.html and
have to refresh.
Open up your app and have to refresh.
Just having Gulp handle
all that stuff for
you is just going to make your life
as a developer so much better.
There's also a lot of sort of pre or
written Gulp files out there.
If you check out a scaffolding
tool such as like or
if you clone someone
else's repository for
a project typically they already
have sort of a build process setup.
And you can just go about using their
build process to work on their project.
Or, like i said,
you can use Yeoman to use a generator
that sort of sets all this up for you.
But I'd say for the first couple
times your using this tool and
kind of understanding how it works,
and understanding what some of these
processes and workflows are It's best
to just kind of start doing it yourself
writing your build tool by
hand a couple times two or
three projects because you'll learn so
much and
it'll be that much easier to dive
into somebody else's project and
look at what they're doing and
say okay I see that he is minifying
the code in this file and running it
through this optimization process.
Ok.
So it's definitely a good idea to
sort of try these things out for
yourself and trying out gulp-jasmine
is a great place to start.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Thanks Michael,
and thank you so much John.
We're almost out of time.
So any parting thoughts John?
>> Just that it can be a little
intimidating to get started on
a build tool like Gulp or Grunt,
and I totally understand that.
They're certainly A little
different than some
of the work that you're
probably going to be doing.
They're kind of doing a lot of
the boring stuff that we'd rather not be
doing but are kind of important.
But In the grand scheme of things,
it's just going to make your life so
much easier using one of these tools.
And it's good to get started now,
when you're already sort of
absorbing all this material and
you can kind of begin including small
steps of this into your workflow.
By no means should you try to
write your whole workflow now.
I would say, maybe for the next
project you work on, maybe just try
getting gulp set up with it and have
it identify your files, and that's it.
From there,
just worry about building the project.
And then as you think about more things
you want to be able to do with Gulp.
Try integrating those processes and
pieces one step at a time.
So like I said, you know?
For example, maybe one project,
just minify code.
Maybe the next project,
you include live reloading.
you include some image optimization.
There's by no means no hurry
to really learn these.
But I'd say every
developer I know uses them.
So it's important to know them
eventually as a front end developer.
>> It's great to get started
right now with baby steps though.
>> Mm-hm.
Definitely.
Well, that's all we had.
Hope this was helpful.
John will be putting up the transcript
on the black cats category,
and we'll see you next
week in a webcast.
>> Yeah.
>> We'll let you know
when we'll be about.
John and I have some docking to do.
Yes.
Yes, we need to figure
out what to do next week.
The write-up 2 will be up in
probably about 20, 15 20 minutes.
So you can feel free to go to again,
the broadcast channel of the discussion
boards for the frontier nanodegree.
And, you should be
able to find it there.
I just have a few more things
that I gotta throw in there.
And, yeah that's pretty much it.
>> Well, all right.
Thank you, bye.
>> Yeah, thanks for coming everybody.